house cobrowse my name is papa yandere
simulator once again Oh germs I never
get tired okay please I never get tired
of it cuz the game keeps getting updated
and a new update came out at 15th of
November let's check it out together so
basically this is my spirit animal in
this game if you're not familiar you can
change the panties and if you're not
already sold onto the game after that
then I don't know what to tell you
I'm feeling very itchy go see I know my
an emu alright let's just go to school
right away and check out what's new
about this game I think you'll be
surprised what it looks different so
apparently he made a huge school that
he's been working on for a long time and
I'm just so excited to check it out I
just can't wait I'm just all like
okay damn this place is huge look at
this oh god the bathroom is so creepy
but it looks very pretty patient you
gotta have to make a game by yourself
from scratch I'm sure there are people
helping but still it's really cool all
right there's a new gym as well oh god
there's an outdoor pool what's going on
up here
all right I don't like I see oh yeah
there's a bunch of new characters in the
game now hi friends how are you yeah all
right mate
yeah all right you're [ __ ] alright
mate yeah I want to drag them BofE at
the same time it's a nice panty shot
let's see if we can get a nice panty
shot damn don't cover up your panties
woman there it is saved okay let's reset
cuz that's this is a bad idea
alright let's check out the new high
school guys I hate fishing you high
school [ __ ] that sucker Rhett Reese I
don't never mind everything's beautiful
this is really awkward looking up the
pea nice I'm someone who looks like this
alright sorry [ __ ] that let's say let's
check out more this [ __ ] is still here
I hate her it's so beautiful it's so
nice
alright so let's check out the main
feature of this new update besides the
amazing building there are now they're
sent by love you you're my big I love
you okay so this girl as you can see is
a coward this guy however it's the
teacher's pet alright interesting
creatures pet as well a [ __ ] [ __ ]
ass [ __ ] the school distilled with
[ __ ] come on they're all teacher's
pet what a [ __ ] [ __ ] oh god
that's creepy
he doesn't care that someone's just
right up in his face they're all
teachers pets ah here we go so this guy
is part of there's a club featuring the
game so this guy is a hero
which basically means that if I kill
someone in front of them how about this
[ __ ] right here jesus [ __ ] christ
oh no simply saw me I do [ __ ] I [ __ ]
up look at that guy
that's right [ __ ] you got judge spy
sent by [ __ ] you gonna dine Heil
[ __ ] I'm sure that if somebody actually
got to know me he would get over the pad
the part of me being a psychopath killer
but that's for another game all right so
I [ __ ] up all right come on let's try
not murder anyone in front of senpai all
right come on there you go
Hey
oh oh he's fighting me okay this is the
feature that guy's a hero f r RQ q f
what the [ __ ] is that girl doing that's
really cool so that's the new feature of
the game say if you want to like be able
to beat the heroes you have to study in
physical education and stuff like that
okay that went a little faster than I
expected
alright that guys oh god yeah that guy
is impossible to beat [ __ ] all these
haters man why can't I just do what I
love you know without people criticizing
me it's [ __ ] there is supposed to be
also a little Easter egg [ __ ] that [ __ ]
oh god I missed what do you do yes what
do you think you're doing whoopsie the
[ __ ] that I just do okay
Oh spooky spooky spooky I gotta kill all
the skeletons [ __ ] you make your
skeleton
I think you can beat me actually you're
doing a really good job come on yeah
yeah [ __ ] what are you gonna do about
it
[ __ ] Oh Shay you got fun okay what is
that I better run the tracks there is
supposed to be a secret room that he
didn't want it say word is where I said
my god I'm gonna go through every
[ __ ] hallway if I have to
oh god there's way too many rooms
careless oh my god I didn't think I'm
fine it what the [ __ ] okay I don't know
what kind of school this is but I love
it oh no one leaves his high school
until I say so
all right let's see our katana yeah
that's a good weapon all right here we
go
good night good night good night good
night [ __ ] play
don't touch me [ __ ] [ __ ] off
[ __ ] all right
they're all dead they're all dead
everyone is dead because of me I did it
for you senpai identify yeah my boobs
are huge snap I was all alone all alone
ha ha ha look at my text
alright that was it for this video thank
you both so much for watching leave a
like if you enjoyed I really would like
if you love some pie and I see brush in
the next one as always stay awesome bros